so there's something about going out of
the uk in australia right it's it's i
think we've talked about this briefly
before
but
it's it's the first time i've ever had a
culture clash or not culture shock i
should say right
it's always related to like
whenever you go on a trip with some
people from another country and you got
to decide how much alcohol you're going
to buy
because for it's it's it's like you get
such a weird spectrum
depending on who you go with yeah you
just never know but for some reason with
it with brits and australian it's always
like a you always have like an agreed
amount that everyone everyone's just
like we should buy more right yeah you
you and the way you do in the uk is what
was a reasonable amount of beers you
would drink in a day yeah and add 50
percent home yeah and then that's your
portion of the beers yeah yeah because
you know maybe someone drinks a little
more than they expected maybe you drink
more than expected if not you have more
for tomorrow yeah beer will never go to
waste yeah yeah so buy more yeah exactly
because like the first time the first
time this ever happened to me when i was
just like shocked right was because like
i i you know i understand when you know
some people don't want to drink alcohol
that's completely fine right that's i'm
just like cool but the first time he
actually surprised me was uh i was it
was my first american convention right
and we were gonna hang out at a friend's
place right it was just a group of us
and it was me and one other person and i
was like we should get some beers for
back home and i'm just and he's just
like great good idea i need a beer yeah
right so we go to the fridge right
and i go in and i take out a six pack of
beer as you do right of course as you do
if you're going to take some beer back
for home of course then you take a six
pack get some extra yeah and he he he
follows me walks in
grabs a single can of beer
and then i just i just i just look at
that i just look at him and i just go
what's that he goes it's my drink for
the night i'm just like
are we drinking or are we drinking i i
thought we were going to drink alcohol
and he was like are we drinking
he was like yeah we are we're drinking i
was like
how long was i going to last you yeah it
was like oh no this this is my drink for
the night when i say i could go for a
beer i don't mean a single [ __ ] beer
i know i was just like yeah we were
going to go for a beer right who stops
at a single beer
did i need to be more specific
i could go for a six pack of beer and i
remember the second time this happened
to me was the camping trip actually yeah
you remember when we were we so
in camping you have one opportunity to
buy everything you need for the night
right so that shopping trip you've got
to think about the entire state that
you're yeah right because you're not
gonna have another another opportunity
because we weren't we weren't exactly in
the city yeah and the the shops there
are only open for a cert set amount it's
like 40 minutes away yeah so we're
getting the food and everyone agrees oh
do we have enough food oh maybe we
should get some more food yeah and like
we we fill out this shopping cart full
of food right
and then then the alcohol discussion
comes along right and uh
it's uh it's it's uh me joey and luke
who's from northern ireland so you know
we were just like let's go let's get a
crate of beer of course right and how
many people were on the trip again there
were like six of us there was six of us
so like a single crate of beer in my
mind
a single crate of beer to last six
people well how many how many cra how
many beers are in this crate 24 24 okay
okay so it's a 24 pack of beer now a 24
pack of beer to me for six people uh
like
it's not enough beers to last the entire
like day potentially yeah and like the
night if we're counting like we're
probably day drinking exactly 24 hours
that's like on average four cans of beer
personally that's not gonna last a day
at least 330 mils as well
uh yeah like the standard candy
yeah it's too small far too small right
and i'm like like i i i i
have two pints each yeah yeah exactly
exactly that's not gonna be enough i
grab a single pack of like i go out i
grab a uh pack of beer with the
assumption that okay this is where we
start right and i remember i remember i
was going to put it on the shopping cart
and uh because we we all agreed that we
were going to drink this trip by the way
we it was something that we all agreed
to yeah and i remember i uh i bump into
eddo right and he sees the pack of beer
and he's like i'll go for a hard night
are we
i'm just like
i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is this is the minimum this is the
minimum this is this is the start this
is the start i remember i remember going
to the shopping cart and i remember
putting the pack of beer on there and
i'm like
so we're getting more now so we're
getting more right guys and it was the
[ __ ] padme meme right again right
everyone's like i i don't know i don't
know i remember when he said that i did
like the family guy like slow head turn
off like
you want
at least double that
this is beer
yeah so so like so after that i'm just
like i take joey and luke to a corner
and we're like it's like emergency
meaning hey guys emergency meeting i
don't think we've got enough alcohol
with us
so like well we kind of don't want to
look like alcoholics like in front of
our mates so let's not buy another pack
of beer whatever let's just let's just
buy some spirits
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's get like some
boxers if you're with a crowd or you're
like i don't
want to scare them i'll just get a
spirit yeah because the bottle doesn't
scare them when they see like the
mountains of beer cans they're like oh
god oh god it's a hard night yeah yeah
you know when in reality it's probably
one bottle of smirnoff or half yeah all
right what party animals we are yeah
how how long did the 24 crate last year
like three hours
did you run out
well if we didn't buy another one
yeah we ended up buying another small
yeah
and it was mostly
i'd say between three people maybe a 24
pack is good enough for a full right
right night drinking starting early yeah
eating and talking all night yeah what
i've realized is that how you need to
like decide on like the alcohol amount
whenever you hang out with someone new
it's just like there's an alcohol mount
for brits
and aussies and you know anyone from the
uk yeah and then and then there is just
everyone else with the exception of like
unless there is an exception right i
always bring way more than i need just
because someone's gonna
drink way more than they said they were
gonna drink right yeah it always happens
and there's nothing worse than it being
like you know 9 p.m like you're in front
of the fire and then someone goes hey
can i get another beer and there's no
beer yeah because like a lot of people
are worse like like to me that's just
second nature because like i think i
you need to buy more alcohol than is
needed because nobody like running out
of alcohol when you want to drink more
it's like the word god i sound like also
awesome
i'm just saying this
i agree i guess there's no worse feeling
so you want to be the bro who provides
for the team yeah yeah you know oh you
run out of beers you bought your own
product i got i got a few yeah yeah go
come and grab a ball go grab one yeah
absolutely don't worry about it and i'm
just i've just kind of realized hanging
out with people from different cultures
like that's the weird part because
normally everyone's everyone keeps
asking for more and then you get to a
point you maybe you run out and some
people are just completely fine with
that and i'm like when i am at like peak
tipsy i'm in the buzz zone i do not
wanna run out of beer no yeah yeah i
know
before i sleep i'm going to sleep like
[ __ ] i i i need this
i need this buzz to keep going man i
need this buzz until i fall asleep
otherwise i'm [ __ ]
i feel like [ __ ] i wake up in the
morning feeling awful help me out man
i'm gonna down a bottle of water or two
before i go to bed i'm gonna feel great
don't ugly exactly
yeah i mean that's uh
that's the alcoholics anonymous class
right
i feel that just how it is when you're
when you're from britain or australia i
think i think i'm going to understand
how ingrained is in the culture and i
feel that further accentuates when
you're on a camping trip oh yeah you
don't know what it is about it i don't
know what it is about sitting around a
fire where you're just like man i need
camping is you know there's a reason why
it's considered one of those manly
activities
and because mentally activities are
normally judged by either how
intensively they are how intensive they
are physically
or how much beer you can drink doing
them yeah fishing is considered a very
manly sport because you can drink beer
the whole time while you're doing it you
know what do you know why i'm gonna say
it how the [ __ ] can you enjoy these
activities if you're not drunk no that's
the thing
it's like is it hanging out with your
friends camping to most people yeah
hanging out with your friends cooking
[ __ ] food getting drunk very fun yeah
awesome
cooking bacon to a char and then giving
it to your mates and being like bon
apple teeth like that's amazing
no i've never heard that before wait why
is that
born apple tv it's a
[Music]
i actually forget the at the original
because i say the memoirs
what is the original bon appetit
i always say the mean one so i can't
bone apple teeth i always say burn apple
tea
you never heard this i've never heard
it's literally a subreddit where people
like have like uh
it's like spelling mistakes it'll be
like my my autistic guitar or something
yeah acoustic
it's those kind of spiders
it's very funny
burn apple teeth